[Música]
bienvenidos a reporteros el magazine de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de france 24
soy herminia fernández comenzamos
mal y se encuentra bajo un embargo
regional y durante las últimas semanas
ha estado en una encrucijada
experimentando una oleada de
nacionalismo y panafricanismo que se
extiende por todo el país la junta
militar que tomó el poder mediante un
golpe de estado en agosto de 2020 ha
tardado en cumplir su promesa de
programar elecciones democráticas
entretanto el presidente francés
emmanuel mccomb confirmó que las tropas
de su país de sus aliados europeos y de
canadá se retiran de malí después de 10
años las operaciones contra el
extremismo yihadista en la región del
sahel continuará con un traslado de las
misiones militares a níger por su parte
la junta gobernante en bamako está dando
la bienvenida a miembros del grupo
paramilitar ruso wagner su presencia ya
ha sido reportada en ciertas zonas del
país aquí la historia de civil país
[Música]
20 de enero de 2022 es el día de las
fuerzas armadas en mal día de gloria y
consagración para un gobierno de
transición cuyos puestos clave están
ocupados desde hace dos años por
oficiales golpistas este es el nuevo
hombre fuerte del país así en vigor está
un coronel de las fuerzas especiales de
39 años llevado al poder por el pueblo
de malí el coronel está dilatando la
transición a las elecciones democráticas
que se ha fijado y desde hace algunas
semanas mal y sometido a un embargo
regional se encuentra en una encrucijada
atrapado en una fiebre nacionalista y
panafricanista los aliados de ayer
incluida francia que lleva casi una
década desplegando miles de tropas en
una fuerza anti yihadista están siendo
suplantados por los recién llegados
china y rúsia
el problema de la seguridad de mali es
un problema importante
porque sin eso nada funciona
china por supuesto trabajará para que
malí la ecowas se unen para encontrar un
consenso
para encontrar una solución y resolver
la crisis actual sanz comenté votos
comenté es posible
la delegación rusa no es muy ruidosa
pero es aclamada por la multitud
regulares a verla papel de manita
[Música]
estamos en la casa de mohamed ya de 30
años nacido y criado en la capital
maliense como muchos de los presentes
mohamed es un ferviente partidario del
poder militar
ya
que está recostado de hecho recoja la
manta el otro es así migoya y el pequeño
que se ha recostado es salió cámara me
gustan mucho esas personas y las apoyo
por eso les di a mis animales los
nombres del presidente del primer
ministro y el ministro de defensa
[Música]
lippi las personas lesionadas
desde los padres fundadores de la
independencia ha seguido un ideal este
ideal es ver la emancipación de los
pueblos africanos me inscribo en esta
perspectiva para abordar mejor esta
lucha y ver el desarrollo general del
pueblo americano
lo que hemos visto con francia desde
2012 hasta ahora lleva nueve años con
qué resultado todos los días se quema un
pueblo se asesina a mujeres embarazadas
se les quema vivas se matan niños
por eso queremos diversificar nuestras
alianzas no queremos más injerencias no
queremos que ningún país esté a francia
u otro nos imponga su elección
es 22 de enero y es otro día de
movilización en las calles de bamako una
semana antes cientos de miles de
malienses respondieron al llamamiento
del gobierno para salir a las calles y
denunciar las sanciones regionales
contra el país
este nuevo encuentro está organizado por
el grupo quiere walk o the bubble gum
para el núcleo duro de la juventud
nacionalista maliense la manifestación
se convirtió rápidamente en una diatriba
anti francesa
[Música]
[Aplausos]
estoy muy contento hay un sentimiento de
orgullo un sentimiento de patriotismo
que me impulsa soy muy orgulloso del
pueblo maliense y del pueblo africano
[Aplausos]
[Música]
la procesión de varios miles de
manifestantes recorre una ciudad durante
varias horas y se fueron engrosando sus
filas
[Música]
esta manifestación es un éxito total
para mis hermanos malienses a mis
hermanos africanos allí para apoyar a
mali realmente esto me contuve mucho una
vez más digo gracias
[Música]
y
reclamos que se hacen cada vez más
evidentes
[Música]
y elegir qué parlar y si los que tienen
ponen toda su fe en rusia para mí son
malienses son colegas manipulados
la evidencia es que las autoridades
actuales han cambiado el debate
se movieron hacia el terreno de la
manipulación
el debate se centra en el respeto del
plazo de transición
en estas manipulaciones las que empujan
a estas personas a apoyar a las
autoridades de la transición
y exigir la llegada de rusia y sus
mercenarios
de la risa
y
los jóvenes soldados a los que no les
gusta ir al frente a luchar contra los
terroristas suelen aprovechar el
estancamiento para derrocar regímenes
elegidos democráticamente
y una vez en el poder no duden en traer
mercenarios para luchar contra los
terroristas
duró el combate translate terroristas
pero en nombre de qué soberanía
estos mercenarios son los paramilitares
el grupo wagner el brazo armado de la
influencia rusa en el extranjero siria
libia moçambique república
centroafricana y recientemente malí la
cuestión de la presencia militar rusa es
un tabú este denunciante corre grandes
riesgos al llevarnos al aeropuerto
militar de bamako donde tienen su base
las fuerzas rusas
a la europol
en el aeropuerto hay una zona reservada
para el contingente ruso que llegó hace
poco y a la misma
también está en el min suma y los fa hma
hay carreteras que han sido cerradas
dentro del aeropuerto para que no se
pueda ver al contingente ruso
saben que este tema divide a los
malienses
hay muchos aliados que nunca aceptarán
que los paramilitares luchen junto a
ellos por eso no hay comunicación
alarcó que hasta 3 aún por la grand slam
para qué
y salvos y que santa amalia
también saben que algunos valientes
herederos del primer presidente multi
bocata también están en contra porque
para ellos la defensa de la integridad
del territorio debe ser responsabilidad
exclusiva de las fama
donde se ven las antenas y las
instalaciones
ahí es donde tienen su base los rusos
ahí es donde descargan sus equipos
todas estas descargas se hacen con la
máxima discreción
aquí es base aérea 101
es en esta base donde se reagrupan las
fuerzas rusas
wagner o fuerzas convencionales y
cooperantes la duda persiste no vamos
más lejos con el trasfondo de una guerra
fría virtual la presencia de la milicia
rusa es en gran medida alimentada por la
guerra informativa que las potencias de
ayer y de hoy libran hermano señoras y
señores hola y bienvenidos a nuestro
canal de youtube la información los pone
en la cúspide del mundo el grupo
paramilitar ruso wagner tiene previsto
intervenir en territorio maliense con
4500 hombres que se desplegarán a partir
del 11 de noviembre la franja sahelo
sahariana y cuya misión será luchar
contra el terrorismo y apoyar a las
fuerzas reglamentarias de malí y sus
aliados vecinos ante los retos de
seguridad en la región
las imágenes que se ven en el vídeo no
son reales tenemos todo lo que podría
parecer un periódico realmente serio y
eso es lo que los internautas
desinformados no pueden detectar
encima
alubia yo y sus compañeros blogueros se
pasan el día rastreando las noticias
falsas que inundan la red y polarizan en
extremo el debate público en mali es una
tecnología asequible y es una
manipulación que funciona muy bien
porque son imágenes que se superponen
estamos en un contexto muy particular en
mali con todos los acontecimientos
actuales y el golpe de estado la
destitución de los militares que están
en el poder este nacionalismo que está
ganando fuerza esta atención diplomática
entre la junta militar y las autoridades
francesas es realmente propicio para la
difusión de información falsa cada parte
trata de ganarse la opinión pública
[Música]
dirección cat y la ciudad de guarnición
en las alturas de bamako desde aquí se
han preparado muchos de los numerosos
golpes de estado en mali el último no es
una excepción
mohamed es hijo y hermano de soldados su
familia es oriunda de cali
[Música]
realmente esta colaboración con rusia es
la solución a nuestros problemas
durante 10 años el ejército francés
estuvo no funcionó y desde la llegada de
los rusos en pocos meses hay resultados
sobre el terreno junto a la fama
el coronel así me tiene el apoyo de
todos aquí
a los 80
[Música]
cómo logra mantenerse relativamente
moderado
todos están exaltados en mali en este
momento en burkina faso en guinea y se
las arreglan para ser moderados que hace
la diferencia cada uno tiene su propia
visión de las cosas su propia percepción
de lo que la gente tiene que entender es
que hay una diferencia entre la vida
política francesa y la población
francesa igual que hay una diferencia
entre la vida social maliense y la
política ahí es donde hay confusión eso
es
incomprensión confusión pero también
países al borde de la ruptura mientras
malí sus nuevos aliados empujan a
francia hacia la salida esta nueva vía
maliense que se extiende cada vez más en
el sahel es también un salto a lo
desconocido para millones de africanos
occidentales
hasta aquí reporteros de france 24
recuerde que para sintonizar esta y las
emisiones anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web france24 puntocom
hasta la próxima
[Música]